Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Good Morning!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today for our 97th episode!
Congratulations on waking up early today!
Ruffians, you did it!
BAU BAU!
And just like that, we're gonna start a new week.
A big week.
Altogether!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I definitely see maybe some new Ruffians with us today.
Not a lot of Ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
What is this show?
So, to explain for you!
Right there!
Who are maybe joining us for the first time, or maybe the 97th time.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start
Start your day off on the right paw.
Tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Hashtag hashtag is back.
Hashtag hashtag hashtag.
Moco-chan's not saying that.
It's nice to celebrate all the small things, huh?
All the small things.
No matter how small they are.
They matter to you.
Yes!
If they matter to you, then they matter enough.
Yeah.
BAU hashbrown hashbrown.
Is that your breakfast today?
Two hashbrowns.
Well, you know, FUWAMOCO Morning, there's a lot of official breakfasts for FUWAMOCO Morning.
Natto being one of them.
We can make hashbrowns one of them, too.
Hashbrown, hashbrown, FWMCMorning.
Who yelled out to me?
Moco-chan, are you ready for natto today?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
But... Sadly enough... Sadly, today is a really happy day.
It's the start of the week.
I'm in a form of good morning.
First time in a little while here.
Well... There's been another Pero Sighting.
Haven't been able to escape that yet, no.
Well...
Let's take a look.
Okay.
Where was Pero seen this time?
De-den!
That looks pretty nice.
Yeah.
What?
I don't know, it's been such a long time since we saw Pero, but... I don't know, he's looking a little bit different.
Pretty good here, right?
Pretty good.
Right, he looks cute.
Cute Pero.
I don't know if I'd go that far, Ruffians.
That's pretty far.
That looks... I don't know.
Fluffy?
Really?
Maybe have a bit of a fluffy time while we're... We FUWAMOCO, we're working like dogs!
Huh?
Yeah...
Filters working one more time.
Probably.
Wow.
You know, it seems that Pero was spotted on the off-kai, an event that happened recently in the US.
Yeah!
And Biboo and some of my senpai were guests there, right?
Right.
Nice.
Where did Pero get to go, huh?
Right.
Interesting.
It's good that Pero left Biboo alone.
We would've heard from Biboo for sure.
I saw that nasty dog.
That's what Biboo would say.
Ruffians!
Why are you calling him a punctual and polite pupper?
He's Pero.
Pero?
He's not polite.
He's nasty, Ruffians!
Yeah.
Not polite.
Yeah, I don't know.
Like, here the filters are working, the lighting is good, you know?
Maybe.
Seems a little fluffy, a little happy, you know?
Maybe because you're gonna give him some blonde rings.
Not the same as Pudding.
Not the same as Pudding, but it's definitely never had any pon-de-ring.
Why would we give him some hugs?
I guess that was nice of you, Ruffians.
Don't be mean to Pero!
You would understand, okay?
You would understand.
But I guess that explains everything, why he looks so fluffy.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know, and I guess he was probably happy to see a bunch of Ruffians at the event.
You know, he could use you as his advantage.
Yes.
Gotta be safe here.
Yeah.
But look!
You know what?
Those pon-de-rings on the left there.
The left!
They look extra cute, right?
Why a little different?
Maybe not so delicious, but a little more fluffy.
A little more pon-de-ring-plushy?
Yeah!
Too cute!
Mine's cuter than Pero-hai.
Yeah, I want them now!
Yay!
We hope you had a bunch of fun at all caramel fields!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
So cute and the dogs chewed everything!
Thank you.
BAU BAU!
I'm glad you had a bunch of fun!
Yes!
We need to hear more from Biboo, huh?
Yeah!
We saw a bunch of photos on Twitter, right?
Yeah.
Wow.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You know today's our 97th episode!
And it also marks the day that FUWAMOCO Morning is back!
BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you for waiting, Ruffians!
I think it was a bit surprising for all of us, but you know, FUWAMOCO Morning had to take a bit of an unexpected break there for a little bit.
A little bit of off-air time.
Yeah, it wasn't our plans at all, but there were some sudden changes in our schedule, and they were out of my paws.
Out of my paws!
We had to take a little break from streaming entirely for a little bit.
It's been busy.
You know, we BAU BAU'd a bunch about it, but there was just, you know, nothing we could do about it.
We're sorry for making you wait, Ruffians!
We know it was super rough.
It was rough for us too.
No fun.
I guess we missed you.
I miss you Ruffians.
But now, we're back!
And we're approaching our 100th episode very soon!
Very soon!
So 97th episode, Wednesday will be the 98th.
Friday the 99th.
And a week from now, Monday, it's going to be the big day!
You know, a week from now is really not long.
Exciting!
You sleep once and it'll be next week, okay?
The math checks out.
But Moco-chan, now your barker is barking all fuzzy in a good way again.
More or less, right?
Right?
FUWAMO makes it a...
Recently, there's been some especially late nights for us recently.
One's that FUWAMOCO didn't
BAU BAU!
But we're looking forward to many many more FUWAMOCO Mornings with you!
To celebrating our 100th episode!
The first year anniversary of FUWAMOCO Morning!
And many more special moments!
BAU BAU!
I forgot about that.
It won't only be the 100th episode, it'll be the first anniversary soon.
Scary!
I still very very much remember the first FUWAMOCO Morning, the zero episode, the part.
Very scary.
I don't think it's been a year, but it has been a year.
Wow, frightening.
BAU BAU!
But!
What?
Wow, we have all those exciting things coming up, but Ruffians!
We also just recently hit a huge milestone!
FUWAMOCO, we just reached our second cover song with over 1 million views!
BAU BAU!
It is Kyutono Kanojo!
Thank you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for listening to over and over and over and lots and lots.
It definitely reminds you of the demon dogs in us, right?
Oh, FUWAMOCO, you know FUWAMOCO's favorite person?
They're dogs.
No!
We are demon dogs.
Thank you.
Oh my god, dogs.
Demon dogs.
Yeah.
We hope that you'll continue listening to our music.
Watch to it!
It makes us really happy, Ruffians.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Also!
Not just that, that's a big milestone!
Just within the past few hours, we also reached over 850,000 YouTube subscribers!
850,000 Ruffians, right!
BAU BAU!
Such a big milestone!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Now we're getting closer and closer to our goal of 1 million subscribers on YouTube here!
Why?
What happened if it became 1-2-1-9?
Right!
That's how the math works, right!
Somehow!
I don't know!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
We'll continue to have a bunch of fun together with you!
Protect your smile, and then, you know, one day, maybe we'll make that big dream of ours come true!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
It's a good idea!
Very good idea!
The best way!
Send a FUWAMOCO clip to them, your favorite one.
Moco-chan, do you have a recommendation?
The one from Minecraft.
Is there only one from Minecraft?
One of them.
Like?
The one that...
That one.
Okay.
Do you know which one I'm talking about?
The no one.
That one's good too.
The pickaxe one.
Yeah.
Do you know which one that one is?
Thank you, Ruffians.
Could be any stream.
It could be any stream.
Hi.
Yeah.
Mama!
Wow, Ruffians, we continue to go forward towards our big goals and dreams.
But!
Somehow, we're also already halfway through the year.
Yeah.
It's June!
June, not July.
And... Did you know that it's June?
Huh?
It's a summer time-ish, but it also means...
Weddings!
And parties!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
BAU BAU!
You know what?
This time it's a bit different compared to our previous voice packs because we recorded it together!
Together!
Both FUWAMOCO and surprise!
Twin FUWAMOCO boys!
Together!
Ruffians!
In one voice pack!
Yeah!
It's the first time that, you know, we've ever released a voice pack quite like this before.
Up until now it's been a Fuwawa voice pack, Mococo voice pack.
Yeah, but we've heard a lot of things from you, Ruffians.
Yeah.
I'm glad you like it so much.
Yeah, a lot of things.
Might kinda make you curious, Ruffians.
Curious?
Please go check it out on the official hololive shop.
There's a one minute sample.
That's pretty long.
Kind of embarrassing.
It's pretty long and kind of embarrassing.
Go check it out.
You're blushing so... I was blushing so hard too, okay?
Yeah.
And if you go and check out the sample, I think you might blush too.
So...
Go take a listen!
Okay, we have it in both English and Japanese in our Special Voices Tour.
Please check it out, you know, especially if you maybe kind of wonder what it would be like to get married to twins.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, and now you can remember, okay, it's June, not July.
June Pride, not July Pride.
Makes sense.
Going away for July, huh?
But, June.
Moco-chan, you said it's kind of summer.
Kind of summer.
No, it is summer.
Because, Ruffians.
Recently, there have been so many exciting things going on in hololive English.
These are a lot of them.
hololive English Summer.
Have you been able to keep up with them so far, Ruffians?
Yeah.
What are you looking forward to most right now, huh?
I see some Ruffians here that are making a little bit of confused faces.
Well first, just a few days ago during our content writing collab with all of Advent, we announced the official start to the Summer of Advent!
It's summer of advent in the year of FUWAMOCO!
It's summer!
Advent!
And a big first point of this exciting summer is an apparel collab together with OMOCAT!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, OMOCAT, they released a really really cool, super cool apparel and went for a myth and council before, so now we know.
We're really happy to be a part of the OMOCAT apparel family!
Advent, yeah, we're cool too.
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
So you have to look forward to it.
There will be more designs, more info, and more excitement coming up very soon!
So please keep your eyes open for it, okay?
You can also check out the Summer of Advent website for more information.
That way you don't get lost on all the exciting things.
We enjoy our super hot, super fun Advent Summer!
BAU BAU!
My eyes are peeled!
Thank you!
Make sure you put sunscreen on them too.
Maybe, just maybe.
Come on, Advent.
Advent of Summer.
But!
Most excitingly, Ruffians!
Ruffians!
It's happening!
Advent!
Come on!
We all announced that we'll be having our 3D debuts this summer!
How?
We are so extremely excited!
You're ready, I'm not ready.
I'm ready but not ready but I'm ready!
Yeah, we're practicing and preparing like crazy right now, Ruffians!
3D.
Yeah.
The BAU BAU in 3D.
Right!
Wow, the fluff and fuzz in full 3D!
Yeah!
But I think we're even more nervous for this now than I did a year ago.
Yeah.
Nervous.
But excited!
But nervous.
But you know, we'll finally be able to show you our fluffy and fuzzy selves and do so many fun things that we always dreamed of doing with you, Ruffians!
Please look forward to it, but not too much, but please look forward to it!
And if you could also cheer for Advent lots and lots as, you know, we keep working like dogs toward our big baby days.
We're all working really, really hard and we're looking
For everyone's daily daily assignments too!
But!
But?
That's not all, Ruffians!
Huh?
hololive Idia!
No.
We just announced our second concert!
Breaking Dimensions!
BAU!
The Broken!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be making our 3D stage debut very soon!
I'm so excited.
I don't think that I...
Moco-chan.
Breaking Dimensions.
It's... Two days.
Huh?
Yes.
Two days.
It's two days!
Not tomorrow.
Two days!
Not one day.
Yeah!
It's not tomorrow.
It's August 24th and 25th.
Yeah!
Two days, Ruffians!
Two days!
And right now, Ruffians!
You can get your streaming tickets on SPWS on Spawn!
So please check them out!
And see, you can also get your exclusive merch sets right now as well!
The order period is rather short and it ends within a few weeks.
So please don't forget, okay, Ruffians?
This way you can get your merch before
Right where your cool t-shirt have your cool towel.
And most importantly that way.
We can see you waving around those blue and pink ten like us!
Of course there will also be ticket sales for the venue tickets!
But they will also be very limited.
And they're sold on a first come first serve basis.
Not a lottery system.
So Ruffians...
Please do your best in the battle, okay?
We're cheering for you!
Do your best, okay?
We'll show you just how fluffy and fuzzy we are on the stage of K-Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
It's gonna be the best way to end off the summer.
Just in case you're a bit confused, Breaking Dimensions is not our 3D debut.
It is not our 3D debut, no.
We'll be making our 3D debuts here before!
Before, okay.
Before!
So don't worry, okay!
Let's look forward to it, okay!
Yeah!
Right.
That means it's gonna be before the 24th, 25th of August.
Exciting!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Ruffians!
An exciting new start to the week.
And sometimes the week can be a little rough even though there's exciting things.
So that means, Moco-chan!
You're gonna show everybody just how strong you are.
Challenge yourself to something you're not the best with.
NANDO!
BAU BAU!
Just like all the previous weeks, Moco-chan's gonna challenge herself to overcome her dislike of NANDO.
When Fuwawa asks me, are you good for it?
No!
Moco-chan's like, can I do it on Friday?
That defeats the purpose.
The purpose is not for you to try and eat some natto.
It's for you to challenge yourself at the beginning of the week.
You know, and so Ruffians, they can do their best to challenge yourself to new things.
Friday!
That's kind of late to start.
The week's like almost over.
I mean, if you're gonna start, it's a good time to start.
Now is always a good time to start.
But, not Friday.
So Moco-chan is going to do her best to eat natto.
Natto!
It's a common breakfast food in Japan.
It's really healthy for you.
But not many people like it.
Not many people!
It can be acquired.
It's an acquired taste.
It's really fine.
I'm sure enough people like it.
I like it!
It's delicious!
I want to be able to eat it.
It's good for you, but it's difficult.
Didn't you already say it was delicious?
I did.
There was a bean stuck to it, so I took it.
I got a new one today.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why is it kombu dashi?
Oh, because that's how it is.
Oh, you're not putting it in though, right?
I was gonna put it in for you.
No, no, no, please don't!
No, I don't want kombu dashi.
Okay.
Wow.
Moco-chan, recently you haven't been the best with challenging things.
I know.
But!
Okay, now stir it in, Moco-chan.
I think I stirred it in.
There might be a bit of wasabi bubble in it.
It smells really good, Moco-chan!
You're gonna beat your personal record today, right?
No.
What was my personal record?
Eight beans!
Yeah.
Why?
How did I do that, though?
You did it.
So you can do it again today, okay?
And that way you can give confidence to the Ruffians, too.
And then, you know...
Be able to protect the Ruffian smile for many, many years with the power of all the good vitamins of a natto, right?
I did it with sesame oil!
Well, today you have wasabi, so... Good luck!
Okay, FUWAMOCO-chan first.
Let's say thank you to the farmers in Canada and the United States of America who work hard to make this.
Yeah.
I tried getting another natto, but it's still firm.
Canada and America.
BAU BAU!
Thank you for your voice!
Moco-chan.
It's really gooey!
Why is it so gooey today?
Moco-chan.
Wasabi's gonna be rough?
I don't know.
It's like strong flavor, strong flavor.
I think it'll be good.
If anything, I feel like you need more wasabi.
Okay, Moco-chan!
Hurry up!
We're over time!
What about the Doggie of the Day?
The Doggie of the Day is the girl you're happy with who gets cut!
The air conditioning made it waft into my face!
Okay, Moco-chan!
Here we go!
One bean?
One bean, okay!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Just wait, just wait!
No, no, wait, just wait.
There's too many, it's too sticky!
We're gonna be strong.
Oh, it's falling.
No, no, no... Moco-chan!
You can't do... Did you just spit it back into that?
It touched my tongue, okay?
I just dropped it off of my tongue.
Moco-chan, if you don't eat a bean, this is gonna be the worst... The worst weekly challenge ever.
Why not?
Should I put the dashi into it?
No!
No?
No.
See, this is why we have to do this on a regular basis, okay, Moco-chan?
It's really cold, though.
That's good, no?
It's actually better at room temperature.
It's healthier for you.
Yeah.
Pon-de-rings are waiting for you, Moco-chan!
The pon-de-rings are waiting for you!
It's too late at night for pon-de-rings, okay?
Actually, I heard that they're changing the recipe for pon-de-rings.
And that they might be using natto from here on out.
So you better get used to it, okay, Moco-chan?
Here she goes!
Try again!
This is looking better.
Okay, okay.
FUWAMOCO-CHAN!
IT'S TAKING ME A WHILE!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Well, today was the worst attempt ever.
Yeah, Moco-baby is back.
And now I have to eat this.
Thanks, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
Oh, Ruffians.
Just remember when there's something rough this week that comes in front of you.
Okay, I'm gonna do it!
I'm gonna show Moco-chan just how much stronger I am!
I'm not a Moco baby!
I'm a strong Ruffian!
I feel like I am dealing with enough challenges this week, okay?
Some of them can't go as great as others.
So, this one, that's okay.
Other challenges, I'll work harder.
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
I think that's fair.
You're not wrong.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I'm ready to see the Doggie of the Day!
Are you ready with me?
Yeah!
Well, today's Doggie of the Day is... Today is Binba!
Viva is so cute!
That is a puppy.
The nose.
The pink area around the nose.
It's so cute.
Viva is a brand new addition to this Ruffian family.
It sounds like she's doing her best too.
Ruffians, let's give her lots of virtual head pats next.
Lots of support!
She's doing her best in this new family.
And you know there's lots of rules and new people to get used to.
It can be surprising sometimes, huh?
It can be a little rough at first, but... Hang in there, BIMBO!
Hang in there, BIMBO!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
How does BIMBO BAU BAU?
BAU BAU!
Tiny BAU BAUs.
They'll get bigger.
You'll get bigger, yeah, huh?
BAU BAU!
But Bimbo's just a baby!
A baby!
She's new to everything and... Bimbo baby.
You know, that also means that there's some very exciting and cute discoveries to be made.
But maybe also some stumbles along the way too.
Make sure you catch her, okay?
Yeah.
We're rooting for you, Bimbo!
BAU BAU!
So cute.
Bimbo baby.
Yeah, but Bimbo... I heard Bimbo can eat natto.
Yeah.
Not the biggest baby here.
BAU BAU!
See the stuff.
Do it!
Moco-chan, do you feel like you wanna go for a walk right now?
Yeah.
Well, let's see, Ruffians, where have you been going for a walk?
And then maybe Moco-chan can go up and follow you.
De-den!
Oh!
Wait, is this a lion?
That looks like a nice, relaxing, refreshing walk!
Maybe a good place to go when you need a walk, huh?
Maybe we need to get away from your sister.
Maybe.
But look!
Hi!
Moco-chan, there's a lot of friends.
A lot of friends at this welfare camp.
Good new friends to replace my sister with!
Dogs and birds.
Much better, huh?
A super cute hedgehog!
That's an improvement.
Not so fluffy, maybe spiky.
Spiky.
We can be fuzzy and spiky together.
Yeah.
But...
That photo!
Right?
It's amazing!
Yeah, you got an amazing photo of the hedgehog too!
It's too bad that the fox was a bit too fast, but I guess you know they have places to be, right?
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day we have de-den!
Hi Fuwawa!
Hi Mococo!
BAU BAU!
I noticed that I've honestly started to build up a lot of draft tweets that stay in the shadow realm.
So do either of you often make tweets that either never leave the draft zone or get started over from the beginning for something better?
Yeah.
Actually, I was just looking at my drafts the other day because, you know, our phones.
I have my drafts and Moco-chan, you have your drafts.
Don't you, Shiori?
And there is a lot of draft tweets that do never make it out to you, Ruffians.
Most of the time though, it's not really that important.
It's a little silly.
I saw one talking about how I need to use all the bath salts because I bought extra bags on sale, but then I forgot about them.
And then you forgot about that tweet too, huh?
Yeah!
Yeah, and there was one about Mama Puppy.
Mama Puppy was like, FUWAMOCO, I'm busy right now, so I'll phone you back in 20 minutes.
And it happened hours.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, you had a voice quest?
A voice tweet.
Yeah.
I think it might be probably...
Some tweets that we don't understand anymore.
Some very similarly nitty tweets.
There's some dream tweets, too.
I forgot about them, but then I saw them.
Oh yeah, the dream was cool!
So... Yeah.
Yeah.
Re-do.
Release them!
Release the tweets!
Send the needy tweets!
They'll all be very similar, but slightly different.
Yeah.
They're stuck there.
Don't know what to do with them.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
FUWAMOCO Morning is back, and we want you to be able to share your works, your questions.
I know you have lots of questions, Ruffians.
Send your questions!
Yeah, your Pero Sightings.
Pero's around and about, but we're not too sure where, so let us know where you saw him so we can not go there.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Take FWMC scoop for any cool news or interesting things you see going on in hololive.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Wow.
On our next team, we have De-den!
Dogs organized neatly!
By dogs.
It'll be my first time!
I've already played it.
I did a very good job organizing the dogs neatly.
But this time Moco-chan's gonna be with me.
I guess we're gonna start where you left off, huh?
Yeah, so you better be pretty good, Moco-chan.
So Ruffians, please help us!
Yeah, we will definitely need help, okay?
It's pretty puzzling sometimes, so... Please help us out, okay?
BAU BAU!
And we released a brand new schedule.
Our first schedule in quite a while.
But after that we have FUWAMOCO Morning this week.
It's FUWAMOCO Morning.
We're gonna be spending it with you Ruffians.
So do your best.
Episode 100.
Set your alarm clock to three.
And then we'll also be playing more Donkey Kong Country 2.
See how the
This nest is holding up.
More Touhou Fuujin Rokui no Mari Senchou Senpai gave Moco-chan a bunch of new hints and tricks.
We're so close to clearing it!
Now you have to show that you still remember and that you can get closer to finishing it.
We have some more Bambi readings.
We can do a new game.
Japanese horror game?
I don't know, it looked very cute, so I'm gonna give it a try.
And then some more Minecraft!
If you see us try to explore Minecraft for the first time and do things wrong that are apparently common sense, I'm done with the Doggy Pack!
We're gonna be watching Hachi a Dog's Tale.
I first watched a lot in quite a while, so we hope you're ready for a movie night too, our friends.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians who are joining us through the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO award!
It's BAU BAU!
We're back!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for joining us today, Ruffians!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Salute!
BAU BAU!
Crash and Spring!
No Monster!
BAU BAU!
P-boy!
Do-boy!
BAU BAU!
Lord Ashton!
Shiryu Fukai!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!